WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED THIS OF THE OF FIVE
I'VE BEEN A TO READ DIRECT
REGARDING PUBLIC- PARTS THAT
AND THE SAN TO HELP THE OF
EVERY HERE TODAY. WHILE I PULL
FOR PUBLIC AT TO THE DISCUSSION
TO THEIR ROOM FOR THIRTY SO
WE'RE HAVING PHYSICALLY THIS
AND PERCENT. CAN ONLY A CALM IF
YOU MEMBERS AND THEN CONTENT IS.
AND A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE
PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO WE CAN KEEP
SIXTY THE SPACING PROCESS AS
THE GOLD IS SIMPLE BECAUSE HER
THE PUBLIC ENTER LEAVE THE
CAPITAL AND FOR THE HERE TODAY
TO MAKE PUBLIC AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. TODAY WE WILL
BEGIN WITH. CON BEFORE MOVE ON
OUR VOTE ONLY A- IF MEMBER OF
THE- IN THE WHICH IS SPEAK WILL
RAISE THEIR HAND AND I WILL
HAVE THEM TO A- THE MY- WE WILL.
ALSO HAVE PUBLIC VIA. I WOULD
ALSO ASK THAT THE- RESPECT THE
SICKLE. AND NOT TOUCH
MICROPHONE. YOU WILL HAVE
MINUTE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. YOU
CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE
YOUR PUBLIC COMMON IS DONE OR
RETURN TO RECEIPT THE POLICE UP
SERVICE THIS. A POLY THE CAP.
INCLUDING LIMITING AN ELEVATOR
YOU SEE TWO PEOPLE AT A TIME.
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO COMMENT. SEEING NONE.
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE
PHONES THE PHONE NUMBER IS ON
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE THE
AGENDA YOU SHOULD ALSO APPEAR
ON THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE
STREAMING THE HEARING THE
NUMBER IS. 877-692-8957 IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR. THREE SEVEN. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE
NINE AND A STAFF MEMBER WILL
ASSIST YOU WE ALSO ENCOURAGE
THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE WRITTEN
TESTIMONY. THIS CAN BE
SUBMITTED AT BUDGET SUB FIVE AT
ASM DOT CA DOCK- OF AN ASSAULT
LISTED THE EDGE. CAN OPERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE A THE PHONE FOR
PER COMMENT. IT PERSON HAS ONE
MINUTE IN GENERAL. OKAY THANK
YOU AND ON THE PHONE LINE TO
YOU WISH TO PUBLIC ON TODAY'S
CALL PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO NOT AT T. OPERATOR WILL
GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER OFFLINE
AND THEN PLACE YOU BACK IN THE
QUEUE. WHAT TO GET FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME-
MADAM CHAIR WILL BEGIN APPLYING
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CAMERAS ARE PRETENDING
CALIFORNIA COALITION YOUTH
CALLING ON ISSUE THAT ONLY
ISSUE. POINT HERE AND ONE ACT.
I RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE TO THE
ONE ON GOING TO FUNDING FOR. AT
ONE SIXTY THAT THIRD OF OUR
YOUNG. IF HOMELESS AND ANY YOU
CAN DO IT AT THE- THEM DURING
VULNERABLE. DURING THE PANDEMIC.
WOULD BE CRITICALLY AND- LOOK
OF THE- YOU IN YOUR THERE CAN.
THANK. THANK YOU. SIX OVERALL.
FINE CAN PLEASE GOING. GOOD
MORE- DANIEL I'M AFTER THE G.
BE OFFICERS OKAY. WOULD LIKE
SPEAK TODAY THE COMMITTEE
WRECKED ON F. SIX EIGHT WHICH
READ A VERY SUCCESSFUL STATE
REFORM BY SUPPORT ALTERNATE TO.
AS WE TALK THE OF DATA THIS PRO
HAS A OF TO SHOW REDUCE PRESENT.
AND SAVINGS TO THE OF OVER
BILLION TO ACCIDENT THE
STABILITY OF PROGRAM TRACKS
DIRECTLY TRANSLATE TO KEEPING
IN THE AND OUT OF. SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORK CLOSELY THE
LARGEST TO DO A LONGER TERM
SUSTAINABLE. TO KEEPING SB SIX
SEVENTY EIGHT I REQUEST
ALTERNATIVETO CUSTODY AND WE
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE
HISTORICAL SUPPORT IN THIS
PROGRAM- ADDITIONALLY IN
BRIEFLY I WOULD LIKE TO LOOK
ALSO COMMENT ON THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND EXISTING
JUDICIAL COUNCIL PRE TRIAL
PROGRAM. AT TO MAKE IT STATE
WIDE WITHOUT A STATEWIDE
FRAMEWORK TO CREATE STANDARDS
OF IMPLEMENTATION DODD AND
OTHER FACTORS PARTICULARLY
FOLLOWING THE HUMPHREY DECISION
THERE'S LIKELY TO BE DIFFERENT
APPLICATION AND THE USE OF PRE
TRIAL WHAT IS NEEDED IS A
UNIFIED APPROACH TO PRE TRIAL
THAT SUPPORTS THE FAIR SAFE AND
EQUITABLE. OF JUSTICE THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE TIME. OPERANDI
SKIN ONE SECOND. HI THERE. ONE
MINUTE PLEASE OPERATOR- LET ME
GO AND START QUORUM CAN YOU
PLEASE PICK THE ROLE. GARCIA
HERE JONES SAWYER HERE LACKEY
STONE BALLADEER. THANK YOU ARE
A PLEASE PER THANK YOU FOR. BUT
NOT YOU MADAM CHAIR AND WE WILL
GO TO LAW THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD THERE. GOOD MORNING MADAM
AND MY LED PEACE HAS ON BEHALF
OF AFTER AYE YOU CAL. CALLING
ASK SUPPORT FOR THE VOTE ONLY
ITEM TO A- THE GOVERNOR'S.
BUDGET ALEX IN SUPPORT COURT
FINDING AN FOR THE PROPOSED-
VOTE AT. TO PROJECT THE TRAILER
BILL MY- TO A PERMANENT FROM
PROCEEDINGS WE OUGHT TO LOOK
VERY FOR TO CAN. CONVERSELY
WITH YOU ALL- AS THEY WERE LED
TO EQUAL OUT TO. PRE TRIAL
RELEASE. AND IMPORTANT
EXPENDITURE TO AND THAT COULD
USER HAVE ACCESS TO THE CALL.
VIA QUARTERSTAFF PARTICULARLY A
IT RELATES TO AN END TO THE
TREE. WAIT AND BUT CORPORATE
PERSON FUND THANK YOU. THREE Q.
ELEVEN IF YOU'D LIKE TO AND
NEXT WE WILL LINE FIFTEEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
WHO COULD BE PROVIDED FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS- WOULD
LIKE YOUR EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THE MAY REVISED
PROPOSAL. REGARDING THE
PSYCHIATRIC IN PATIENTS-
PROGRAM- THIS LIST MAY REBUT
REPORT WILL REPRESENT A MAJOR
POLICY SHARE- FROM THE STANDARD
OF TREATMENT AND THE TREATMENT
MODEL THAT WE ARE OPERATE IN IT.
GRAMS FROM A TREATMENT BASED
MODEL TO MORE CUTS THE BASE
MODEL ALTHOUGH THAT THE MEMO
THE- PROPOSAL LIMITING IT TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS THAT WORK MASSIVE
AMOUNTS OF OVERTIME. DURING THE
PANDEMIC. I TOOK A 10% PAY CUT.
WELL AS- THESE PEOPLE PROVIDE
THE TREATMENT TO COPE WITH THE
PATIENTS AND GOT. FROM JUST
DOING THEIR JOBS THE CRUEL AND
UNUSUAL PUNISHMENT Q. A- GROUP
OF PEOPLE THAT ARE THERE JUST
TRYING TO DO THEIR JOBS SO WITH
THAT WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOU KNOW GO ON- THE PSYCHIATRIC
INPATIENT PROPOSAL. THANK YOU.
AMEX WILL ALIGN NINETEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS COULD SEND
THEM BACK THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIPS AND COULD NOT FIND
ONE I'M JUST WANTED TO COMMENT
ON BOTH ONLY ISSUE FINALLY-
ITEM NUMBER TWO IN THERE AROUND
ACCORDING TO THE FIBERS OF
CRIME BUMBLEBEE. I'M JUST LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL OF
YOU TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S
APPROPRIATE FUNDING AND THE
FINAL BUDGET YOU- PREVENT ANY
CUTS TO CRIME VICTIMS SERVICES
AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT PREVENTION EFFORTS TO
PREVENT DOMESTIC AND SEXUAL.
VIOLENCE ANOTHER CURRENT THANK
YOU. NINE TWENTY YOU ARE OPEN.
YES MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS TO SET
MY CAROL WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY I'M
CALLING IN TODAY- RELATED TO
VOTE ONLY ISSUE TWENTY FROM
ISSUE NUMBER THREE AND THAT-
WITH HIS- ISSUES RELATED TO-
FOR ACCESS TO JUSTICE AND TO
REDUCING COURT ORDERED A DEBT-
WE ARE REALLY THANKFUL TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR CONTINUING INTO A
LOOK AT THESE ISSUES AND TO
INCLUDE THEM IN THEIR IN THE
BUDGET. AS WE GO FORWARD I'M AS
YOU KNOW WE- ARE LOW INCOME
CLIENTS ARSON GROUNDING IN DEBT
DUE TO TRAFFIC COURT AND
CRIMINAL FINES AND FEES WE
REALLY NEED TO GET RELIEF FOR
FOLKS AND WE ALSO NEED TO JUST
SUPPORT PEOPLE AND- COURTROOM
WITH COURT REPORTERS AND
TRANSCRIPT REIMBURSEMENT FUNDS
TO PEOPLE CAN DEFEND THEMSELVES
ADEQUATELY FROM ADDICTION WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S WORK
AND LOOK FORWARD TO MORE WORK
GOING FOR THE. NEXT COUPLE OF
WEEKS THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
WE WILL GO ONLINE TWENTY TWO
YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS ON THE LOTUS AND I AM A
PREVENTION PROGRAM MANAGER WITH
THE WOMEN'S CENTER OF
STANISLAUS. THE SHAPE THE MAIN
REVISIONS INCLUSION OF A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND
BACKFILL FOR THE VICTIMS OF
CRIME ACT. FUNDING AND URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO INCREASE THAT TO
TWO TO THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS. I ALSO
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO INCLUDE
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONGOING FUNDING FOR SEXUAL
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PREVENTION.
VENTION WORKERS THE KEY TO
SHIFTING CULTURES IN THE
DRESSING ROOT CAUSES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. OUR PREVENTION
PROGRAMMING DEPENDS ON ONGOING
FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
OUR WORK IN THE SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITIES. IN ORDER T HELP
PREVENT AGAINST SEXUAL AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND BUILD
HEALTHY COMMUNITIES. FOR
HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS AND
CONSENT FROM THE NORM. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. WHY TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING SURE NUMBERS ARE
BANKAMERICA REPRESENTING THE
BRADY CAMPAIGN AND STRONG
SUPPORT AS VOTE ONLY IF YOU CAN
STEP ISSUE NUMBER FOUR EIGHT
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT AND CAL THAT THANK
YOU. AND MADAM CHAIR THERE ARE
NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR HELP THIS
MORNING. WE WILL THEN MOVE ON.
TODAY WILL BE CLOSING OUT OUR
SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE WITH THE VOTE
ONLY AGENDA. ALEXION'S WE WILL
BE TAKING TO THEY ARE ON THE
ITEMS FOR THE SUBCOMMITTEE HAS
BEEN HEARD IN A PREVIOUS
COMMITTEE HEARING. WE
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE EFFORT ON
WORK THAT MINISTRATION THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
ARE SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF OR
BUDGET STAFF AND ALL THE STAFF.
THAT HAVE MADE ALL OF THE
VIRTUAL HEARINGS POSSIBLE AND
THE PUBLIC FOR THEIR INPUT AND
PARTICIPATION. AS INDICATED THE
AGENDA WILL BE CLOSELY NOT MANY
AND FOR LEAVING OPEN ONGOING
BUDGET DISCUSSIONS AND ISSUES
THAT ARE LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES. AND WE WILL BE
WORKING THROUGH THESE ITEMS
WITH THEIR SENATE PARTNERS IN
THE COMING DAYS. SO WILL BEGIN
VOTING I WILL BEGIN BY VOTING
ON ISSUE ITEM ONE. REYES BUDGET
PROPOSAL FOR THE MILITARY
DEPARTMENT THE ACTION IS TO
ADOPT THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
ON THE SIDE I'M STILL WE HAVE A
MOTION. WITHIN SECONDS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. GARCIA HI JONES
SAWYER LACKEY HI STONE FIVE
VALDERS. THANK YOU THAT IS OUT.
BUT ONLY ISSUE NUMBER TWO FOR
COMMITTEE ON REVISION OF THE
PENAL CODE IS TO APPROVE THIS
BUDGET THAT WE HAVE A MOTION.
SO MOVE THEN SECOND CODE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL GARCIA. I JONES
SAWYER HI NIKE NOT VOTING.
STONE BUT THE ORDER IS NOT
WORKING. THANK YOU THAT MEASURE
IS OUT- BUT ONLY ISSUE NUMBER
THREE FOR THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
AND JUDGES RETIREMENT SYSTEM
VARIOUS BUDGET PROPOSALS THE
ACTION IS TO APPROVE US BUDGET
AT THE TOP THE PLACEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL FOR ITEM THIRTEEN
DO WE HAVE A MOTION. TECH MOVED
AND SECONDED CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL GARCIA HI JONES
SAWYER HI MACKEY. STONE
BALLADEERS. THAT IS OUT THANK
YOU BUT ONLY ISSUE FOR IS FOR
THE JUDICIAL BRANCH'S HELP
HEALTH CENTER AND THE ACTION IS
TO ADOPT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION THAT WE HAVE A
MOTION. WELL THEN SECOND PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. GARCIA I JONES
SAWYER HI BLACKIE FIVE STONE
BOB THERE IS. THANK YOU THAT IS
OUT. BUT ONLY ISSUE FIVE IS THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH'S PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE AND THE TRAILER BILL
PROPOSAL FOR THE ACT AND THE
ACTION IS TO REJECT THESE
PROPOSALS. SEN MOVE THEN
SECONDLY TAKE THE ROLE. GARCIA
HI JONES SAWYER LACKEY STONE
ARE THERE. THANK YOU WHAT ONLY
ISSUE SIX THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND AB FIFTEEN OH SIX
OFFICER INVOLVED SHOOTING. THE
ACTION IS TO APPROVE THE BUDGET
RESOURCES AND REJECT THE
PROPOSED PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
ALLOWING THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO AUGMENT THIS ITEM
WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE APPROVAL DO
I HAVE A MOTION. SECOND WITH A
SECOND PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
GARCIA HI JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY AYE STONE. SAW THEIR
SIDE. THANK YOU. THE ISSUE THIS
OUT BUT ONLY ISSUE SEVEN IF THE
DOJ FIREARMS AND SAVE HANDGUNS
PROPOSAL AND THE ACTION IS TO
THE ADOPT THE L. A. L.'S
RECOMMENDATION IN THE AGENDA.
THE MOTION. SECOND WITH A
SECOND PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE
GARCIA I JONES SAWYER HI
BLACKIE NO STONE RIGHT NOW
THERE ARE. THE ISSUE WITHOUT
VOTE ONLY ISSUE EIGHT IS THE
DOJ HEALTHCARE RIGHTS AND
ACCESS WORKLOAD AND THE ACTION
IS TO REJECT THE PROPOSAL DO I
HAVE A MOTION. SECOND MOVE THEN
SECOND PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
GARCIA I DON'T SWEAR BY LUCKY
FIND STONE. ARE THERE IF
NOTHING. THAT IS OUT. BUT ONLY
ISSUE NINE IS VERY IS THE OJ
BUDGET PROPOSALS ON THIS ISSUE
WILL BE PULLING ADAM FOR THE
CONSOLIDATED FORENSIC SCIENCE
THAT PROPOSAL AND WILL NOT BE
VOTING ON THIS TODAY. THE
ACTION IS TO ADOPT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR ITEMS ONE
THROUGH THREE UNDERVOTE ONLY
ISSUE NUMBER NINE DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. SECOND THAT HAS BEEN
MOVED A SECOND PLEASE TAKE THE
ROLE GARCIA HI JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY BUT I STONE VOTERS. THAT-IS OUT. THE ONLY ISSUE TEN TEN
IS THE BOARD OF STATE AND
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS ON
VARIOUS BUDGET PROPOSALS AND
THE ACTION IS TO ADOPT THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION FOR THESE
ITEMS WE HAVE A MOTION SECOND.
THEN SECOND PLEASE TAKE THE
ROLE GARCIA I DON'T SAWYER HI
BLACKIE STONE. VALIDATORS THANK
YOU. BUT ONLY ISSUE LEVIN IS
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY IN THE OFFICE OF YOUTH
AND COMMUNITY RESTORATION AND
THE ACTION IS TO ADOPT THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND PLEASE TAKE
THE ROLE GARCIA HI JONES SAWYER
BY LACKEY HI STONE. FOUNDER
THANK. THAT ISSUE IS OUT. BUT
ONLY ISSUE TWELVE S. C. D. C.
R. AND THE PROPOSAL RELATED TO
POPULATION ADJUSTMENTS AND THE
ACTION IS TO ADOPT THE ALLEY-
RECOMMENDATIONS. WE'VE BEEN
MOVED AND SECOND LAST TAKE THE
ROLE GARCIA I JONES SAWYER I.
NEKI BUT I DON'T. BOTHER THAT
ISSUE WITHOUT THANK YOU. VOTER
ONLY ISSUE LEVIN IS THE STAFF
COMPLAIN PROCESS AND OTHER
ASSOCIATED PROPOSALS FOR CDC
ARE IN THE OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL AND THE
ACTION IS TO ADOPT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION FOR THESE ITEMS.
SECOND IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECOND LEFT PLEASE TAKE THE
ROLE GARCIA I JONES SAWYER HI
BLACKIE FIVE DOWN. NINETY FIVE.
THANK YOU THAT ISSUES THE TOP
THAT. BUT ONLY ISSUE FOURTEEN
IS VARIAS JERRY CDCR BUDGET
PROPOSALS IN THE ACTION IS TO
ADOPT THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
FOR THESE ITEMS. IT'S BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED- THE SICK
THE ROLE FIRST YEAR HI JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY AYE STONE NOT
VERIFIED. THAT ISSUES THE TOP
THAT. BUT ONLY ISSUE FIFTEEN IS
VERY SCDC OUR CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROPOSALS. IN THE ACTION IS TO
ADOPT THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
FOR THESE ITEMS. IT'S BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED PLEASE TAKE
THE ROLE GARCIA I JONES SAWYER
HI BLACKIE ALL RIGHT STONE
RIGHT NOW THERE IS. THE ISSUE
HAS BEEN ADOPTED BUT ONLY ISSUE
SIXTEEN IS VERY IS MAY REVISION
CDC ARE NON CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROPOSALS THERE'S A NUMBER IN
ERROR ON THIS ISSUE SO TO
CLARIFY THE ERROR I'LL STATE
THE CORRECTIVE ACTION FOR VOTE
ONLY ISSUE SIXTEEN WHICH IS
APPROVED AS BUDGETED ITEMS ONE
THROUGH FIVE. IN A DARK PLACE
FULL HOLDER TRAILER BILL FOR
ITEM ONE. REJECT ITEMS SIX AND
SEVEN. AND ADOPT PLACEHOLDER
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL FOR
ITEMS EIGHT NINE AND TEN. WE
HAVE A MOTION. MOVED AND
SECONDED PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE
GARCIA I DON'T AYE LACKEY AYE
STONE. ARE THERE THANKS THAT
ISSUE IS THE TOPIC YEAR SIR
GREAT THANK YOU. WHAT ONLY
ISSUE SEVENTEEN AS THE VALLEY
STATE PRISON ENHANCEMENT AND
THE ACTION IS TO REJECT THE
PROPOSED FOUR POINT EIGHT
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER POSITIONS.
AN ASSOCIATE OF FUNDING AND
APPROVE THE REMAINING RESOURCES
DO I HAVE A MOTION. SECOND MOVE
THEN SECOND PLEASE TAKE THE
ROLE GARCIA I DON'T SWEAR HI
BLACKIE ALL RIGHT STONE BUT NOT
NOT GOING TO. THAT ISSUE IS
ADOPTED. BUT ONLY ISSUE
EIGHTEEN IS THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES AND THE
ELIMINATION OF VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTIONS THE ACTION IS TO
APPROVE S. BUDGETED DO I HAVE A
MOTION MOVED. THAT'S BEEN MOVED
A SECOND PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE
GARCIA HI JONES SAWYER HI
BLACKIE BY STONE BUT- THERE IS
NOTHING. THAT ISSUE IS A TOP
THAT THANK YOU. BUT ONLY ISSUE
NINETEEN AS AMERICA IS VERY IS
MAY REVISION OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES PROPOSALS IN
THE ACTION IS TO ADOPT THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THESE
ITEMS WE HAVE A MOTION. HELLO
MOVED MOVED AND SECONDED.
PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE GARCIA I
DON'T SAWYER HI MACKEY FIVE
DOWN BALLOT THERE. HEY AND
FINALLY BUT ONLY ISSUE NUMBER
TWENTY. IS VARIAS LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES INCLUDING OVERSIGHT
OF STATE FUNDING TO THE DA'S
ASSOCIATION SUPPORTING
SURVIVORS ARE CRIME INCLUDING
THE MYSTIC VIOLENCE SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
WAITING HOMELESS YOU INCREASING
ACCESS TO JUSTICE FOR
INDIGENOUS INDIGENT FOR CLIENTS
IMPROVING COURT SERVICES AND
SUPPORTING COURT USERS
RECIDIVISM REDUCTION STRATEGIES
AND STRENGTHENING DISASTER
RELIEF AND RESPONSE EFFORTS.
THE ACCESS TO A DOCTOR
RECOMMENDED THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE SAID MS
WE HAVE A MOTION SECOND AND A
SECOND PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE
GARCIA HI JONES SAWYER HI NIKE
FIVE STONE. CALAVERAS THAT
ISSUE HAS BEEN ADOPTED THE FOR
ALL OF OUR ISSUES FOR TODAY
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR- EFFICIENT HEARING
THAT. ALL THE WORK AND STUFF-
SEVERAL THEIR WORK AS WELL
THANK YOU THIS IS A TURN. YEAH.